what are the schools actually doing the
schools aren't teaching students very
much of anything at all instead they're
pushing a radical ideology especially
this trans stuff and we make fun of it
we make fun of the pronouns we make fun
of the crazy haircuts and
but it's really really harmful to
students there's a florida father who
was just testifying before the state
surgeon general he was describing how
the school that his daughter attended
secretly trans his daughter and this
secret transing of the daughter led the
daughter to try to kill herself in the
school
in january of 2022 i went to my
daughter's elementary school to deal
with a very sensitive incident
my daughter attempted suicide by hanging
in one of the school bathrooms
my wife and i were told
by the school counselor
that it happened because of an ongoing
issue with her gender identity
we were in shock because our daughter
never showed any signs of questioning
her biological sex
we were told that they knew about the
gender issue
due to meetings they were having with
our daughter
behind our backs
we learned that during these meetings
our daughter
daughter's confusion
was affirmed
and validated through the use of
fictitious male names and male pronouns
our daughter was living the double life
without our consent or knowledge
this father's restraint is so admirable
imagine especially if you have kids
even if you don't have kids imagine you
do have kids but it's so clear if you do
have kids
you're a sweet little kid aptly your eye
precious you'd do anything you'd throw
yourself in front of a bus for this kid
you send this kid to a school that you
pay for through your taxes
and you assume that you can trust
the people at the school the teachers
and the administrators and then the
teachers and the administrators secretly
fill your precious little kid's head
with lies and fantasies and perverted
delusions and then your kid tries to
kill herself
it would be very difficult to refrain
from violence in that situation
against the perverts and the psychos
and the weirdos at the school who did
that it would be very hard that father
has such admirable
restraint
that's what's going on in our schools
and this is happening in florida that's
why ron desantis has put out this
this mandate to the schools
to say look no more of this
no more of the weird
race education but especially no more of
the weird sex education
up through grade three
the only problem with what's going on in
florida is it doesn't go nearly far
enough
we've got to kick this stuff out of the
classrooms all the way up to grade 12
the weird transgender stuff we just have
to kick it out and if teachers bring
this up at all fire them maybe prosecute
them i don't i don't want to sound
hyperbolic here but this is
an
actual existential threat to society if
men and women don't know
the difference between the two
all right it is a
severe threat to the entire society if
this is what's going on in the education
system and so we have to take it very
very seriously meanwhile the libs are
crying and saying
saying that uh ron desantis is basically
mussolini forget mussolini he's hitler
that's what they're saying because he
wants to limit the ability of these
sickos in the guidance counselor offices
and the administrative offices and the
classrooms for that matter to trans your
little daughter and your little son
what are people going to do about it ron
desantis isn't even able to do all that
much this is still going on desantis
gives out his orders and the teachers
laugh and the administrators laugh and
the state attorney's life and they say
yeah we're not going to we're
the governor gave out his order now
let's see him enforce it text nulls to
989898 the consumer price index has
reached 40-year highs the latest gdp
numbers confirm the u.s is in a
recession whether the administration
wants to admit that or not now is not
the time to have all your money in the
stock market or tied to the u.s dollar
take action to protect your savings from
a highly turbulent economy
now by diversifying at least some of
your investment portfolio into gold and
silver from birch gold group text knolls
to 989898
birch gold will send you a free info kit
on how to transition an ira or eligible
401k into an ira in precious metals
birch gold will even help you hold gold
in a tax sheltered account for decades
investors have relied on gold and silver
as a hedge against inflation you can too
they've got an a plus rating with a
better business bureau countless
five-star reviews and thousands of
satisfied customers so do it right now
text knolls to 989898
get help from birch gold today that is
knowles k w l e s to 9 8 9 8 9 8 to
claim you're free no obligation info kit
on how to protect your hard-earned
savings with gold
meghan markle is launching a podcast
i'm not interested in this story because
i'm interested in meghan markle i'm not
even interested in this story because
i'm all that interested in podcasts
i'm interested in this story because i'm
really interested in politics and meghan
markle's stupid new podcast tells you
pretty much everything you need to know
about how political power is exercised
in this country
people should expect the real me in this
and probably the me that they've never
gotten to know certainly not in the past
few years
where everything is through the lens of
the media as opposed to hey come to me
i'm just excited to be myself and talk
and be unfiltered and
yeah it's fun
i've said this before i'll say it again
i'm calling for a complete and total
shutdown of new podcasts until we figure
out what the hell is going on too many
people have podcasts look i understand
it's rich coming from me i have three
podcasts myself
okay i've got this show i've got verdict
with ted cruz i've got the book club
i'm on other podcasts actually too i'm
on backstage i get it okay but it's too
much meghan markle having a podcast it's
too much
and why does she have a podcast
this woman
was
duchess of sussex this woman was actual
royalty
in the most prestigious royal family in
the world the last really even somewhat
important royal family on earth
she wasn't even just a politician she
was even higher than a politician in
public life
and she gave all that up
to do a podcast
she gave up
having a a an official role in politics
to just kind of be in the media
there's a story that came out over the
weekend
this is a story
about me actually
and some other people too it's from
politico it was a total hit piece on
conservatives who have podcasts it was
called wow politicians are really bad at
podcasting and none of these politicians
are getting it right
and the story was largely about me and
senator cruz because we
have the
most prominent
politician podcast in the country that's
the verdict podcast which hit number one
on the charts and stayed there for a
long time and it's still
is pretty high up on the charts most of
the time and this politico guy hates the
podcast and he he called me a right wing
gadfly which i'll take as a badge of
honor
i'd really be worried if a politico
reporter liked my podcast that's how you
know i'd have to hang it up and find a
new job but i really like he was very
upset he was very bothered he listen to
lots of episodes of the show he
certainly didn't learn anything but
even granted all of that
the very fact that this article could be
written because it wasn't just about me
and ted cruz it was about all of the
politicians who have podcasts as well i
think cruz and i uh senator cruz and i
had the first one and then
afterward it was just this cascade of
politicians starting podcasts sometimes
with co-hosts like me sometimes just on
their own they get a microphone they
record it and see all these politicians
making podcasts and the fact
that that happened tells you a lot about
our political order
which is that
politicians are
starting podcasts
because
there is essentially no difference
between an elected politician and a
media figure in terms of the actual
political influence that they wield in
the country
now
cert obviously if you're in the united
states senate you do still have certain
privileges that the bureaucracy and the
deep state have not managed to take away
from you you can confirm judges you can
ratify treaties
most of the time
but but most of the political power
of elected politicians has gone away
even the u.s senate
which
should be the most important
deliberative body in the world but
certainly the us house of
representatives and certainly a lot of
the state houses and certainly a lot of
the lower elected positions that power
has gone away
to the deep state to the bureaucracy to
the executive agencies to the
corporations through privatization
to the schools
to all the rest of it
the difference between
a media figure and a politician
not so clear these days in fact the most
important thing that most elected
politicians do is go on tv well it used
to be go on tv now that tv doesn't
matter as much anymore it's that they go
on podcasts it's that they go on the
internet it's that they get the message
out there
most members of congress are sort of
glorified press secretaries
or now maybe a little bit more so
because they host their own shows and
they get the message out there but in
terms of the real power that they wield
it's not very much
you compare your average member of
congress
to your average career bureaucrat the
bureaucrat has way more power
to your average school administrator
that school administrator is going to
have a whole lot more power
that's a political problem because the
people still have some say with the
elected representative we don't have any
say with those unelected bureaucrats who
even the president can't really fire i'm
so glad you like that clip now you got
to subscribe ring that bell we hit a
million subscribers love that we got to
hit a billion head on over ring that
bell get the notifications we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you